[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
democracy is on the rise
we are winning
against these fascists
it's happening
one reason is Gen Z they're not putting
up with the [__] they're not gonna
do it they're just not welcome to the
Tony Michaels podcast it's April 5th
it's the day after Donald Trump was
arrested
in a New York Criminal Court you know I
find it hilarious that manga is trying
to act like these 34 felony charges are
nothing oh it's nothing he'll beat this
case good luck [__]
I guess it's not good for Donald Trump
this is not good for manga
it just isn't no it's very good for the
Republican primary it's awesome to win
that but as you know in this country
that is not the majority ideology
proven once again last night in
Wisconsin 11 Point Victory folks
11 points
Wisconsin told the fascist in Wisconsin
in Wisconsin
go [__] yourself it's not gonna happen
We're not gonna have any of this stuff
you're not gonna take away our rights
you're not going to take away women's
bodily autonomy it's just not gonna
happen and you're definitely not going
to overturn elections or try to overturn
our vote with the Supreme Court you can
get the hell out of here
and that is the greatest part
and we will use this
in our messaging and our narrative folks
listen this idea this idea that this
country wants Trump is absolutely
ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous it's
laughable at best that the majority of
this country wants Trump I was in a
Twitter space yesterday
and I know some of you are naysayers
here that are on our side
but you naysayers aren't paying
attention either just like manga isn't
paying attention
the reason why we want Donald Trump to
be and I say we as the pro-democracy
coalition
the reason why we would prefer Donald
Trump be the nominee here's why I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
some facts some data which I don't
normally do I don't normally pile
anything on top of you it's not a poll
it's real numbers
Donald Trump lost by almost 8 million
votes
in the last election the 20 the 2020
presidential election Joe Biden beat him
by almost eight or over 8 million votes
81 million people did not vote for Joe
Biden a lot of those people voted
against Trump the thing is here's the
thing
we don't know where the Ace of
Hutchinson vote is we have no idea
we have no idea where the Nikki Haley
vote Lies We do not know where Ron
DeSantis will win or where he will lose
there's one thing that the Democratic
party knows all too well
and it's where the voters voted against
Donald Trump in 2020.
by a margin of almost 8 million
do you do you not understand how how
vital that is
to running an election to beat Donald
Trump
there is nothing more exciting than Maga
nominating Donald Trump because he is
indicted on 34 felony charges
now I'm going to talk about those
charges here because I read over the
indictment and there there's there's
some things in there that we haven't
heard in a long time it seems new
but the media is missing this manga is
definitely missing what's happening in
this indictment and what is going to
happen to Donald Trump here
they're completely [__] blind to the
facts and and why Alvin Bragg did what
he did
and knowing what he did Now it only
makes sense that Donald Trump is in big
trouble in the Manhattan D.A or the
Manhattan Courthouse Criminal Courthouse
it's not little
everyone keeps saying this is the
smallest case these are 34 felony
charges
30 [__] four felony charges and some
people may say you know pun intended I
guess they're trumped up because they're
going after 34 different transactions
folks
that's 34 transactions where the D.A
convinced a grand jury
with probable cause that Donald Trump
had the intent to cover a crime with
that false business transaction
that fraudulent business transaction 30
[__] four of them
I don't think you're quite understanding
the magnitude
of the legal Jeopardy that Donald Trump
is in right now in in the state court of
New York
this is [__] earth-shattering as far
as his freedom goes
if he were to be convicted and and and
sentenced on each individual count he
would serve hundreds of years in prison
now rather it comes to that or not
that's the politics of it right because
that's what I kept hearing yesterday oh
I I heard one argument
one argument in this Twitter space I'm
not [__] you it's from the guy
it's from the guy he's called brick suit
he's the guy that shows up at all the
rallies in the suit that looks like
bricks right do you know what I'm
talking about do you know this guy he
was in this Twitter space talking here
was his argument I'm not shitty and this
is the best argument that I think they
got this is fantastic that just this
just shows how much trouble Donald Trump
is in
it goes to show you that they're
floating they're trying out all these
this different material you know what I
mean like he tried out material at
Mar-A-Lago last night which was the same
material he's been trying out for the
last three four months
but this brick suit gang here's his
thought process Donald Trump
tricked Alvin brag into charging him on
these 34 felonies and he's playing Five
Deep chess with Alvin Bragg
oh my god listen if you're playing 5D
chess I would recommend that part of
your moves is not to get indicted on 34
felony counts in the state of New York
under the Manhattan DA's office
this isn't some [__] outliers
district attorney
this is the Manhattan District
Attorney's office
under a grand jury
who is indicted Donald Trump on these 34
felony counts
of covering the intention of covering a
crime with fraudulent business
transactions that's what it is
now Alvin Bragg is holding all the all
the cards close to his chest
and we know why why do you think Donald
Trump can't keep his [__] mouth shut
the likelihood that he has a gag order
is high that he's going to receive one
and the judge yesterday didn't lay out a
specific gag order other than the one
that comes with
a condition of his release like hey you
can't break the law and you can't do
these things
but it is likely that maybe there'll be
a gag order and Donald Trump could try
to
instigate the gag order because my view
of it is this Donald Trump is very
vulnerable here if Ron DeSantis wants to
get in the race hey hey meatball Ron if
you're putting ass fingers wants to get
into the race now is the time buddy what
you need to do is you need to fix that
law in Florida so that you can become a
presidential candidate and Governor at
the same time because you won't win
without both of those things there's no
way Ron DeSantis can win
the Republican nomination without being
the governor and being able to run he
can't do it won't happen
and he better start now hit the window
is closing on Trump and opening for
DeSantis but it is not going to stay
open for him very long Donald Trump is
going to make sure to slam it shut
and I know that it's opening for
DeSantis I know it
and the reason why is because Trump's
little speech last night fell flat
fell absolutely flat it's the same old
[__] the same old whining he's
whining and crying and America doesn't
give a [__] that he's paying the price
for his crimes and they don't care if he
whines and cries about it they don't
give a [__]
this is how this is how it works you do
the crime you do the time that's how
most Americans react to most of these
things
and of course when Americans
individually are tied up in a legal case
of course they think it's unfair to them
but most of the time most of the time
it's like well yeah you know you [__]
you [__] did the [__] so
you gotta paint the piper and here it's
Criminal
at least that's the allegation
of the Manhattan Day end at D.A and the
grand jury
on the fact of his intent because that's
the beautiful part about this case in
New York folks every single bit of it
goes to his intent all of it his intent
his intent his intent that's it that's
all Alan Bragg has to prove in court
is that Donald Trump's intent to cover
up a crime with these fraudulent
business transactions that's what makes
them a felony that's why you charge them
with 34 of them and apparently the grand
jury saw enough evidence
and enough intent evidence of that
intent to charge him with these 34
felonies
now there's talk of a doorman and some
love child which is not surprising I
mean we all we all know that Donald
Trump is a is is of course uh has in the
past and continues to probably live some
crazy ass lifestyle we know that and
really that's not the thing I hold
against him the most
it's the crime that really bothers me
when you want to be a leader of the Free
World especially when you have the reins
of power like he would have and did have
just something that the American people
want they want Justice
and whatever that means and to say that
yesterday was a horrible day and a dark
day in America's Nation folks here's the
thing no one really got out in the
streets and cheered no one really got
out in the streets and was upset
there wasn't any Mass violence or there
wasn't any Mass celebrations it was like
yep that's Donald Trump he's a crook
he's a criminal and he should probably
be charged with crimes
period
he's irrelevant
to to 88 of the country he's irrelevant
it's only that 12 percent where he
sticks it's only that 12 that gives him
his energy
because this idea that he he has half
the country is a fraud this idea that
he's a billionaire is a [__] fraud
this idea that he's some kind of tough
guy is a [__] fraud everything about
him his hair the the the [__] size of
his his shoes his height Jesus Christ in
the [__] fake mug shot that they were
selling merch on they're trying to sell
him as six five
even even his [__] fake ass mug shot
that he's trying to grip with his
supporters is a [__] lie
holy [__]
and we're scared of this guy no we're
not we should not be scared of this guy
at all and matter of fact we should
definitely definitely definitely make
sure
that that Donald Trump ruins Rod
desantis's career on his way on his way
to the Republican nomination as well as
ruin the Republican party because folks
I don't know if you noticed this morning
that the Republican party is absolutely
dead they're dead
they're dead
it's done it's it's just a matter of
covering up the hole to be quite honest
and Donald Trump carries a big enough
shovel to D to dig and and cover that
hole for the Republican party and we can
just stand back and watch
all we have to do is make sure we go to
the ballot that's it just go to the
polls and that's it and it's proven time
and time and time again
as he's a [__] loser because last
night in Wisconsin trumpism and fascism
American Maga fascism in this country
lost again Big Time 11 [__] Points 11
points folks
in Wisconsin
now a lot of people want to say oh what
Tony Wisconsin used to be a swing state
in blue that Supreme Court has not been
liberal for almost 25 years
and now it is
and we can be
Wisconsin's can be rest assured that
their bodily autonomy and and their
rights to their Liberty
that the Supreme Court shall protect it
and they did that themselves
that was that was that was the voters in
Wisconsin particularly gen Z I don't
know if you watch some of the footage
from the college campuses
this generation that's coming up this
generation that's coming up
they get it they know fascism when they
see it
they understand what the threat to
democracy is and it's it's not it's not
it's not [__] people who want to make
sure that Americans don't go broke
because of a medical bill
it's not politicians who who push for
affordable college and affordable
education it's not politicians who push
for for children to eat lunch at school
no matter the cost to just feed children
to start school at three instead of five
so they can start their education early
and parents don't have to pay the extra
two years of daycare
this generation knows that one of these
days they're going to want to retire and
they're not going to want to be 80 to
retire and they definitely want to make
sure that the safety net of Social
Security and Medicare and Medicaid is
there for all Americans
they understand what's at stake and what
is at stake is our democracy
our country our Republic and the enemy
is fascism
full stop taking away our rights taking
away our countrymen's rights they're
trying to legislate people out of
existence in state legislators Jesus
Christ we see what's going on in
Tennessee
this generation coming to the Capitol
peacefully protesting
after three representatives in this in
the Tennessee legislator have their mics
turned off aren't allowed to speak on
the floor they protest and now today
they're going to vote to expel them for
practicing their right to protest to
represent their constituents that
elected them duly in the state of
Tennessee and you don't think you don't
think gen Z sees what's happening
you're outside your [__] mind
what a great fight we have in front of
us
this is going to be a more exciting
pro-democracy Coalition than what we had
in 2020 in 2022 for the midterm
it's all in front of us the evidence is
there the numbers are there we know
where the votes are folks
we just have to be pumped for our
democracy and engage in our democracy
that is the most important point
I'm only one microphone
I'm only one you are thousands and
thousands of microphones
use your voice
spread the message
of pro-democracy all across our land it
is what will save it
people are listening people are paying
attention not enough yet so we gotta
keep being loud
but the wind of Liberty is at
democracy's back
and we must open our sales folks
it is time now we are the jury
we are the jury against fascism against
Maga against trumpism the real America
First Nazis are at our doorstep and we
are the D.A we're the judge we're the
jury
we get to vote guilty are not guilty
that's what we get to do and I'm excited
today because on today's show I'm
welcoming a new guest
former United States senator of Alabama
and former Federal prosecutor Doug Jones
joins me today and he's going to be
talking exactly this
how how does the Democratic party push
the pro-democracy Coalition into 2024
and how do we start that enthusiasm and
it starts with the Democratic National
Convention
and he's got an idea of where he won it
and I love his idea so he's going to
talk about that today and of course
since he's a former Federal prosecutor I
definitely want to get
Senator Jones's take on the Trump
indictment yesterday and maybe the
indictments to come so we will be asking
him those questions today and that's not
the only guest I got today folks it's
not the only guest
we got Dr Rachel bidikoffer my favorite
political strategist I believe to be the
one of the best political strategists in
the entire country
she knows American politics forwards and
backwards she knows the history forwards
and backwards she is going to give you a
guide over the next over the next 18
months
to drive democracy to the polls and to
win for Liberty
she's gonna lay it out for you in a plan
and she's here today to not only
celebrate what happened yesterday and
I'm not just talking about the the Trump
uh arraignment on 34 felony counts in
the state of New York
I'm talking about what happened in
Wisconsin and if you didn't see this
coming in Wisconsin you're a bonehead
like seriously
and the reason why I know this is
because of the her opponents the loser
in the race his response
oh my God they seen it coming how we
didn't see this coming
I mean Kansas is a precursor to all this
and we must keep this up we must keep
this going
and we will grow that eight million
deficit
and we will win back the Senate easily
and gain seats we can win back the house
in 2024. we will definitely retain the
president United States to be a part of
the pro-democracy coalition
but I think beyond that we could we
could do much more work in these states
again the wind of Liberty is at our back
of democracy
so open your sails and engage in your
democracy
today's the day not tomorrow not next
week not next year today is the day that
we fight and I I'm excited I I think
these are great wins I believe that that
this is going to uh punch us into 2024
with with great hope
and great enthusiasm
and that's why that's why I'm excited to
have Senator Doug Jones on today because
he's going to talk about where this
convention
needs to be it needs to be in the South
the reason why it needs to be in South
but he specifically wants it in a
certain city in a certain State and I
believe this is a great idea nothing
could be better than having it there so
I I invited him on to come talk about
that and again I'm going to ask him
about the the Trump indictment yesterday
uh some other news um some sad news
about my home state uh I got a few
messages this morning I am okay I live
in Central Missouri but they're
apparently there's tornadoes so everyone
be safe out there apparently it took
some lives in Southeast Missouri this
morning
um there was really high winds and
rained and hail last night where I'm at
um but uh and hopefully there won't be
any more touchdowns today but there
there are still severe storms out there
so if you're listening and you're in a
severe area make sure you're heeding
those warnings and and seek uh shelter
uh if you get an alert immediately don't
do not test the do not test the strength
of a tornado it is it is not a thing you
want to do so if you get a warning go go
immediately don't waste any time your
life is your life is not worth any
property go go save your life and your
family's lives and and make sure that
you stay safe if you're in those areas
where those storms are at because I know
those storms are still out there and
it's going to continue uh like this
probably through the season so
um we're used to tornado season here in
Missouri we've had devastating tornadoes
in Missouri even in the town that I live
in in the last 10 years and it'll
continue that way as we had climate
change and no one wants to do anything
about it but as that continues to happen
so stay safe out there again if you hear
an alert an alarm get safe don't don't
worry about your property worry about
you and your family and your life that
that's more important than anything
um so I I was sad to hear that this
morning but I I wanted to bring it up I
know my excitement
in the beginning
um but I I want to make sure that that
is mentioned as well everybody I am
excited about today's show it's going to
be uh it's gonna be a [__] banger
it's gonna be are you excited I'm
excited I'm excited we're gonna have
Doug Jones uh coming up here in just a
few minutes uh and then we'll have
Rachel bittickoffer at the top of the
hour so hopefully uh Gabe Sanchez will
be able to join us uh for for those
interviews and I hope that we can um
oh boy I hope we can get to the bottom
of uh some of this uh charges the 34
charges I've read part of the indictment
I didn't read it all I skimmed through
most of it
um and I gotta I gotta say I gotta say
the media is really
um if they don't get their [__] together
here they're really my guy's gonna take
this messaging away from away from us
we've really got to be loud about this
it's about the intent
um I'm gonna show you one clip and I
think it was on Morning Joe this morning
where they were playing clips of Alvin
Bragg's press conference and then
Grandpa poopy pants's little statement
last night at Mar-A-Lago and comparing
the two and when you compare them side
by side like they're doing it is it is
um I'll tell you it is it is a very good
it gives you a very good sense of how
much trouble Donald Trump is in here I
mean he's in a lot of trouble now this
this idea that this New York Um
Manhattan DA's case against him was weak
and flimsy is absolutely the opposite
and really honestly the idea that Alvin
Bragg is holding it close to his chest
instead of letting it all out there only
shows you that the strength of their
case is the [__] that we don't even know
yet and it's the evidence of his intent
of the crime that he was trying to cover
up with these business transactions
that's that's it that's what it is
and I think I think that for the media
not to start with the intent because the
intent is the most important part about
this case Alvin Bragg talked about it in
his press conference last night
they don't ha they do not have to prove
he committed crime alls they have to
show the jury on these felony charges
that is that he had the intent of
covering up a crime he thought he did
crime and he was trying to cover it up
and the grand jury with probable cause
found that 34
34 of these transactions were designed
with the intent to cover a crime
that is the most important part is his
intent it doesn't matter federal state
you're going to hear these arguments
over and over and over again and this is
all going to be played out in motions
right they're going to try to knock
these charges down they're going to try
to shut shut this this this prosecution
down because oh well that's federal law
and this is state law and blah blah blah
blah yakety schmackity
and we're going to see it play out in
court and I think the next actual date
that Trump is supposed to appear is like
December 4th I doubt that happens
um I I really seriously do and they're
talking about the trial being next
summer
I doubt that happens like I said the
reason why he's running
isn't
to avoid indictment I mean we know that
now
if that's the reason why he ran he
[__] failed that's why he said he
loses big he's The Biggest Loser because
if his idea was to run was to Stave off
indictment he lost that battle his
intent by running for president of the
United States even though he's not on a
ballot anywhere yet
is to stop these trials from happening
that's what it is that's what it is all
right folks let's go to a quick break
when we come back we should have Doug
Jones former Senator Doug Jones from
Alabama with us I'm going to talk to him
about having the Democratic National
Convention in the South I'm going to ask
him some questions about Trump's
arraignment arrest
and uh his indictments that came down
yesterday everyone don't go don't go
anywhere I'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Hellboy
yesterday Donald Trump and the
Republican Party are the biggest losers
the biggest losers and they know it they
know it they're highly upset
very very very upset
um while we're waiting I'm gonna show
you this um this video here
of the difference and this might be the
only video that I actually show you of
Donald Trump's little
um what whatever it was
whining whining last night if you want
to call it that this is only 41 seconds
okay so it's not very long but you're
gonna get the gist here of
what kind of trouble he's in with this
uh Gabe Sanchez joins me we should have
Doug Jones here in just a few minutes
Gabe Sanchez have you watched um this
comparison video of uh brag statements
and Trump's statements oh he's ah you're
not even ready there we go there we go
okay sorry I I was half I had I had
clips of Margaret Taylor green uh
blasting in my ear and it was the wrong
oh I see I see is that how you start
your morning is uh I mean some people
some people say you know they love a hot
cup of coffee and I say I've got an
alarm that says uh it has Margaret
Taylor green talking about how antifa
was blowing whistles and it actually
actually did you know that a New York
City blowing whistles is illegal oh is
it a crime is that what it is it's not
can you get can you get 34 felony counts
for blowing a whistle uh yeah I'm pretty
sure you know under so she did she did
her a little interview with Brian Glenn
right her boyfriend from rsbn and uh
yeah I've seen I've seen the clip where
where like he kissed her or something
yeah right at the end he's like oh see
you later
that's really weird man yeah it's like
yeah weird I know you guys are doing a
little research it's a little weird but
the idea that uh she was in the car and
this is when she made the Nelson Mandela
Jesus comment and in that like mix of
gibberish and nonsense she says uh uh oh
yeah they showed up with their whistles
and they were in my ears and it was all
this noise and it was antifa and we know
what they're like during the day and we
know what they do at night and did you
actually know that it's illegal to blow
whistles in New York City it's not okay
well also can you imagine if you were
the victim of let's say an attack or
assault
and you blew a whistle and the cops are
like up you know what we were gonna get
this guy that was attacking you but now
that you blew the whistle you're
actually the one that's going to jail
um but in addition to that it's just the
fact that she's like oh well uh you know
it's
it's uh it's just not fair it's not fair
I'm the victim and it's like you know
how you don't get whistles blown in your
face or feel like you're the Target or
you know play victim like that don't
throw a rally in another state that you
don't represent and don't invite people
to it right I mean we went over this in
a Twitter space I don't know it's a
couple weeks ago and I keep bringing
back these Twitter spaces and the reason
why is because like they get all their
talking points from these same people
that show up in their pieces right it's
the tail that Wags the dog and there was
one of them uh it was one of these faces
were like oh Tony are you okay with
people shouting down speakers at
universities I'm like yeah I'm okay with
it you're okay with them with them uh
hampering their freedom of speech look
freedom of speech is both ways people
it's both ways if you can't be loud
enough with a PA system and people hate
you that much at that University maybe
you should consider not going or just
live with the fact that people don't
like you and your ideas because they
suck if your ideas suck that bad that
people are willing to stand and boo you
or blow a whistle and drown you out
because your ideas suck that bad and
they're that terrible I don't know think
about getting some different ideas maybe
yeah or maybe again don't have a rally
in a city where it is primarily uh an
area that is blue or one that doesn't
like Donald Trump so if you're gonna
throw a rally to protest the persecution
of Donald Trump they're coming after you
they're not coming after him okay yeah
yeah they're they're they're coming
after you that's why they charged Trump
with 34 counts of uh of of of uh
falsifying business records and also the
fact that he was arrested in a reign in
court yeah that really means that
they're coming after you okay but most
of the other greens just another one of
these people who played victims she's
already she we went over yesterday she's
she's trying to rewrite the story and
where does she show up she shows up in
Mar-A-Lago last night to do her little
walk right and be like oh my God people
love me this is then you should have
thrown your [__] rally in Mar-A-Lago
not in New York City
right why I mean they they live in that
bubble right and that's what really
[__] her up yesterday is that right
outside her bubble the
maganazi rally bubble right I mean who
who did who did she throw the rally with
oh well tomorrow yesterday no no
yesterday do you know who she did it
with who was it it was uh Jack uh oh
prostate gay yeah yeah yeah prostate and
uh and so they even had they had an
Eventbrite little invite that they put
out there you know and they how long did
this event last you said yesterday did
you count the seconds yeah so actually
actually I miscounted I added 20 seconds
to it her total speech from the point at
which she started speaking through the
like actually had something to say
through the megaphone there was about
five to ten seconds where she like
couldn't she was she couldn't figure it
out in the middle of a speech right yeah
and it's all pointed that out that she
didn't know how to hold the yeah right
right so so then uh she started speaking
again so total time if we include
everything even that Gap in the middle
five minutes 35 seconds if we don't
include it five minutes 25 seconds is
what uh is what her total her total
speech her attendance at that rally she
spent more time walking up to the stage
and leaving the stage then she did
actually talking on stage and then she
was like oh we had hundreds of
supporters that were there if you look
at the photo that they that they shared
90 of the people that were there had
boom mics or were holding cameras or you
know we're we're trying we had a
recorder or something trying to get a
quote
those are the people those are the only
people that were there there were a few
other Red Hats and stuff like that but
ninety percent of the people that were
In This Crowd
were actual here actually you know what
I'll pull it up so people people know
what I'm saying
on the crowd well let me while you're
playing that let me let me pull up this
video of the um the contrast between
Trump's speech and the um and and Alvin
Bragg's press conference yesterday let's
let's listen to the back and forth on
this
every felony counts
buying business records in the first
degree he knew there was no case it was
a felony
it's a falsified business records within
10 to the fraud everybody said this is
not really an indictment there's nothing
here these are felony crimes in New York
state I learned this came to me and they
said there's nothing hit the defendant
repeatedly made false statements
he also caused others to make false
statements charging a former president
of the United States for the first time
in everyone stands equal before the law
that every single I mean it's pretty cut
and dry and and the thing that the thing
that manga is confused about they're
like oh why didn't Alvin Bragg lay out
the conspiracy because he doesn't have
to now he doesn't have to and and he
laid it out for um the grand jury he
laid it out for them the conspiracy
because he doesn't need to prove that
Donald Trump committed a crime all she
has to do is prove that Donald Trump had
the intent to cover up what he thought
was a crime that's it that's it it's all
based on intent
and the grand jury with probable cause
voted to indict Donald Trump on 34
felony charges because there was
evidence of his intent on these 34
counts these 34 transactions and
everyone's like oh these are trumped up
it's all trumped up because they just
did the same charge 34 times I'm like
yeah but if you're if you're looking
through the prism of of Donald Trump's
legal team my guess is the what what I
think Alvin Bragg is trying to say
through the grand jury with each charge
being an individual charge
as he's trying to say to Donald Trump's
legal team and the world I have evidence
that he had intent to cover crime with
every single one of these transactions
like it's not just oh he committed
business one count of business felony
business fraud and we got 34
transactions he's like here's each
transaction here's each charge and we
have evidence of intent with each one of
these [__] things right and also
people that's the way that I took the
indictment yeah no and the other thing
too is people need to read the dates in
those indictments they're happening in
2017. there's conversations that are
happening when Donald Trump is president
in the Oval Office with Michael Cohen
right so people are like oh this is
nothing these are just trumped-up charge
is this and that you have to remember
when these are happening okay he's not a
private citizen anymore and not only
that but holy [__] Alvin Bragg hiding
the lead thirty thousand dollars to hush
up a doorman a Trump Tower for having a
illegitimate child holy [__] that was
something right well you know that this
is the uh the crowd that you were saying
earlier right but that's that's the
craziest part because I was like well
that's new and someone's like no that's
not new they were like posting articles
from like 2017 2018 from the New York
Post and like no this isn't new everyone
knew about this door man the story was
out there but that's the point that's
the point is all this was killed that's
why David pecker is so important and Ami
is so important in this and the reason
why is because it was all catch and kill
right four four campaign finance and
Donald Trump thought he was committing
crime
they thought they were committing crime
rather they did or not that's for a
court to decide that matter I mean
Michael Cohen's already pled guilty Ami
basically signed an amnesty agreement so
so you're not gonna find that out it
doesn't matter though Alvin Bragg from
what from what it looks like from these
indictments my take on it personally is
that Alvin Bragg presented the grand
jury with 34 business transactions that
had the intent of covering up a crime
and Alvin Bragg had the evidence that
those 34 transactions were used in the
intent with the intent to cover a crime
and the grand jury is like yep felony
charge
I mean I want to know I I want to know
where this kid is right this kid is
probably hidden behind ndas oh you think
you think it's real
you think that the the doorman is
telling the truth I I mean why do you
pay a doorman off if it's not true right
well I I mean if that's a good point
that's a good point if the doorman
to someone to say oh Trump had uh an
illegitimate child right A A Child out
of wedlock
if you pay someone off
that's an admission of Truth to the
story okay because if the doorman who by
the way would not have the legal ex the
legal uh representation or the money to
follow up if the story was sold to a
publication and the publication went
public with it right or rather went
public with it you know whether or not
they did their due diligence and their
background their their research and
Reporting
but the fact that a thirty thousand
dollar payment was made to a person
is an admission of the truth okay
there's no I don't there's no there's no
hiding uh I mean Jay Jay brings up Point
Arnold Schwarzenegger had one as well
right that was another moment that was
with the with the that is housemaid
right and why would he lie he's just a
doorman who didn't have a stake in the
story right I'm not I'm not saying I'm
not saying that the doorman's lying or
not lying yeah yeah what what I what I'm
saying is is that the payment it doesn't
matter if there's an illegitimate child
that that's irrelevant just like just
like they're gonna keep saying well
Stormy Daniels said in court that she
didn't have sex with Donald Trump it
doesn't it doesn't matter right it
doesn't matter
the crime that Donald Trump is being
charged with is that he thought he was
committing a crime and he used his
business records to try to cover up that
crime right that and he he made a
fraudulent business transaction to try
to cover that crime that's all that
matters it doesn't matter it doesn't
really matter what was the what what was
the underlying story rather it's true or
not it doesn't matter and that's and
that's where I think um the media this
morning is trying to get off kilter
because they want to get on this this
doorman story they want to go back to
the Stormy Daniels they want to talk
about her tweets and how incendiary they
are because Trump's legal team in Trump
is trying to make this about Stormy
Daniels trying to make it about uh
avenatti I guess avenatti put out some
statement from federal prison about
Michael Cohen they're trying to make it
about Michael Cohen and in fact if it is
about Michael Cohen it's about the
conspiracy that Michael Cohen and Donald
Trump we're in together to try to I
don't know use the business transactions
to cover a crime that's what is being
Char that's the felony that's the felony
they keep saying oh well you can't make
this a felony you have to prove the
crime that a crime was committed no you
do not intent is the only thing that
matters on this charge that's it full
stop 100 intent and all Alvin Bragg and
the prosecutors have to do is show the
jury that on these 34 counts that Donald
Trump had the intent to cover a crime
when he made these fraudulent business
transactions right that's it that's it
that's it that's all no it's pretty cut
and dry and that's why I say this isn't
small like everyone's like oh this is
the smallest case oh I can't believe
they brought this case even even some
even some liberal uh legal Scholars out
there I'm like look man this is if he
gets convicted on all these and the
judge lays down the hammer on sentencing
you're talking in over a hundred years
in in a state prison state prison is not
a prison you want to go to yeah I don't
know if folks I mean there's no there's
no Club Fed here you know so well but
there is there could be that in the in
the mix here and the reason why the
reason why it could be in the mix is
because if he gets tried on on federal
charges right and he gets sentenced to a
federal prison the feds aren't going to
let him go to a state prison first they
are they generally are concurrent
sentences so like as he's serving a
federal sentence whatever this
incarceration would be right they're
serving his State sentence at the same
time I mean it is it is it is something
that uh it is something that would be
interesting to think about is like how
would you know how does that work for a
former president right like
what type of you know is he in a
in like isolation the whole time you
know like we we know how dangerous
certain areas like certain you know gen
pop and other areas can be but like
you've got a former president
who's now in there on the last leg of
his life right he's already vulnerable
defeated
uh I don't even know how that would play
out like if that actually happens and he
goes to prison like what type of in
situation is that like the type the term
in terms of protection right well I mean
those are all good questions and these
are rubicons that we haven't crossed it
right like yesterday but if it was but
if it was a felon then he would lose
like you know I I I don't I don't know I
I think these are all things we don't
know yet and I think that's why Maga
um you know they have a little bit of of
America's year like oh you're gonna
destroy the country like we're not gonna
destroy the country we're just gonna
find out how this stuff works right like
we're gonna figure out how to manage
this and the best way to manage it Gabe
Sanchez is to uh not elect a criminal
like that that would be a good idea
I don't know think of that to be like
maybe this next time we don't elect a
criminal right yeah we don't try to
re-elect a criminal right despite the
fact that we have now shown in all of
these different uh like Donald Trump is
running a [__] uh a medley of crimes
from outside the the presidency and
inside the presidency and so the idea
that you'd be like hey you know who we
want to bring into the presidency the
guy who committed these crimes or tried
to use the office to uh to benefit or or
profit off right the American people
and mag is like he's the best thing
that's ever happened we had jobs and
this and that dude [__] ignore
people and let them die during Kobe you
know what you know what that's right you
know what's not happening this morning
the stock market isn't crashing did you
see that yeah it's not crashing he's
staying stable uh underneath stable
leadership it's not just it's not just
the the Maga that's doing this the
self-defeatists on the left are doing
this too we had one here in the comments
and they're a regular viewer
um and I don't mind calling them out
because I think they're they're um
they're stable enough to uh for me to
call them out it's kinky streets they
were saying something that I don't
understand Trump something like that I'm
like friend friend I know Trump all too
well here's the thing the reason why the
reason why I want Trump to be the
nominee and I think Democrats in the
pro-democracy Coalition should want them
to know is one reason one reason well
there's a lot of reasons but the main
reason is this what happened in
Wisconsin yesterday is going to happen
to Donald Trump that is his fate and the
best part about Donald Trump versus a
ham sandwich whoever the Democratic
nominee is oink we know who it is
um whether you like it or not that's who
the nominee is going to be here's the
thing is that we know we know where 81
million votes lie that are against
Donald Trump I don't know if you know
that or not we we know that much like we
know we're 81 million votes exist in
this country that are against Donald
Trump and if you believe if you believe
that him being indicted on on state
charged 34 felonies in the state maybe
more State charges in Georgia felony
charges in Georgia possibly Federal
felonies for maybe conspiracy to commit
sedition if you think if you think that
that 81 million isn't going to still be
with us and we know exactly where they
are to get those votes you are a
bonehead you are at last night in this
Twitter space they were like Tony listen
we understand that that Donald Trump may
be at apparel here but we think this
strengthens him I'm like with who I mean
yeah maybe the people who weren't going
to leave him anyways but what the [__]
yeah the people I mean like you have to
get out of here you have to look uh oh
man hold on sorry quickly quickly I
thought this was pretty funny dog y42
oh yeah dog white 42 has been throwing
uh homophobic comments on my videos on
YouTube which I think are pretty funny
but also dog white 42 says Gabe looks
like he did Molly at a gay orgy last
night
it'd be pretty fun and now you and Molly
yeah that would be pretty fun but it is
funny to see these people in these
spaces when they oh they they freak out
and they're like oh my God you vilified
him oh he's gonna be a martyr no he's
not okay look again you have to look
back and consider that all of the [__]
that we found out happened after he left
the the White House in January of 2021
okay we have to I realize that
when you have the Mar-A-Lago documents
Jan 6 Insurrection right these are all
things that were investigated after and
are still being investigated Fulton
County you've now gotten the Manhattan
DA's investigation there's probably
other things that have happened you've
got egene Carroll's stuff that's coming
out there like all of these things are
are taking you know hits at Donald Trump
in the background and the guy as we saw
yesterday was completely defeated there
was even a quote from someone that was
inside or was able to hear through the
the
um they had audio that was feeding into
another room and I think it might have
been Kyle Chaney or Kyle Griffin I
forget which one but they said the judge
was like uh you you have to basically
you have to respect what you know the
court right here and you can't you know
say anything more than what your plea is
and he was like I know and had like a
like a [__] Deep Side the guy is done
dude they wouldn't even hold the door
open for him when he came through well
that's because he's a defendant he's not
a former president exactly there's any
other [__] man and a normal
person I mean outside of the fact that
he has protection as he was leading in I
gotta tell you I saw some crazy [__]
conspiracy theories yesterday I pulled
these videos
okay one of them is a guy was watching
uh a guy was watching the the footage of
the motorcade come by right and he's
like all right there's that there's the
communications van he's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa what is that what's going on
there an ambulance whoa whoa why do they
have an ambulance
and his argument is that the only people
who ever have an ambulance in their
motorcade are currently like current
sitting presidents not any former
presidents and I'm like I'm pretty sure
that when you're under the protection of
secret service and uh [__] top-notch
medical you you have to have just like
you have a an area in your home like in
Mar-A-Lago I'm sure they have an area
that has everything he needs blood uh uh
and medical supplies like anything they
need to do like on site right there they
have access to and the fact that they
have a an ambulance there is because
just in case something happens when
they're mobile when they're moving right
if somebody were to attack or whatever
they need those things right away they
would have it but under this guy's idea
he says that because they had an
ambulance in the motorcade that it means
that they're actually that Trump is
actually still president I mean I saw
some [__] crazy stuff yesterday
people saying wait wait a second because
by that logic though then we would go
back to Alvin Bragg couldn't indict him
because he is a president I mean so
which is right exactly it's it is so
crazy but they are on they're online
well some of them are making threats
some of them are like look come to my
door and I will kill you some of those
videos got taken down from Tick Tock
holy [__] so like they're getting
serious well um there was there was this
guy brick suit you know the guy that
shows up in this rally yeah who always
wears a brick suit yeah yeah yeah so he
was in the room yesterday when I started
listening in on this Twitter space right
and yeah because I was on a different
call and you were telling me yeah yeah
yeah this is his theory it's hilarious I
can't even believe that this is like I'm
like okay I get that that's what you're
trying to sell here but that makes it
even worse he's like well I see this as
Donald Trump playing now he didn't say
in so many words like 5D chess he's
saying that Donald Trump tricked Alvin
Bragg into charging him with these 34
felonies because he knows their the
underlying evidence is weak Trump that
is and that and that he's going to be
exonerated from this and this is going
to catapult him into the history of the
best of the best and it's going to
destroy Alvin Bragg I'm like dude so
what you're saying is is that his 5D
chess move is to get indicted in the
state of New York on 34 felony charges
right that's your move but also but also
is there is there some sort of time
travel that's happening because what
he's arguing would be that Donald Trump
knew that he should commit these crimes
back in 2016 2015 2017 and that he was
like you know what I should uh falsify
these business records right now because
in about seven to eight years or so I'm
gonna have to go to court or trial uh
and and be arrested for these things
right so you've got this guy who then
says all right I'm gonna falsify these
business records and Michael Cohen's
like yeah you should definitely do it
that way if we're gonna do it to be
caught right and then he's now saying
that it was all a plan and that scyvance
dropped it because Bill Barr told
cyvanse to [__] or told sdny uh to
tell cyvance to drop it and then Alvin
Bragg came in was like I'm not gonna do
it and then Alvin Bragg later was like
you know what I'm gonna do it like you
had to have all of these different
players and know what was happening for
this to actually play out the way
that he's uh that he's making it up like
that like you it doesn't make any sense
because now they're trying to make logic
out of being cornered to be like well
Donald Trump was arrested and charged
with 34 counts of falsifying business
records and the only way that I can
logically explain why he got his ass
into trouble is because Donald Trump
intentionally did those things to set a
trap for years later for Alvin Bragg to
get him and it's like what the [__] are
we talking about but listen if we expect
um their desperation to show now is the
time to expect it right like this is
this is the time and really it's going
to show more um when when when and if
Jack Smith makes his move with that
grand jury on obstruction because folks
that at the underlying part of all this
of all these investigations in the Trump
the mo is his intent of obstruction
that's always that's always what he's
doing is obstruct obstruct obstruction
and he tells us he says look right
they're coming after you they're not
coming after me all I'm doing is
standing in the way that's obstruction
right if you stand in their way that's
obstruction right if you have if you
have people like Jim Jordan Jim Comer
Lindsey Graham and other people try to
stand in the way to to act as like a
block for Trump right that's obstruction
right they just the only way that the
Republican Party
can fix the crimes that they've
committed is to commit more crimes
of like by blocking the crimes it just
doesn't it doesn't make any sense for
them it makes completion it's not
supposed to make sense the magonomics of
it they're like look if we go to the
Whiteboard it makes total sense right
right yeah red lines and I mean when you
start talking about magnomics here it
really starts to fall apart because the
magnomics that my 5D chess trumps 5D
chess move is to get is to trick Alvin
brag into into getting your grand jurors
right before getting a grand jury to
yeah to to indict him on 34 felony
counts are you kidding me that's the 5D
chess move come on man he's playing the
long desperation is showing he's he's
playing the game okay yeah yeah well it
happens that way well we're gonna get
the political intake and why we should
be so excited not about just exactly the
Trump and uh arraignment yesterday but
also what happened yesterday in
Wisconsin this is big news for democracy
and it means a lot and let me tell you
if if the Republican party doesn't today
shape up what happened in Wisconsin last
night is is bound to be our future in
2024 it is up to us to do it and we must
stay engaged in it but I have someone
that's going to show you and tell you
exactly how to do that where the battle
is going to be we've got Dr Rachel
bittickoffer stick around don't go
anywhere
we got doc right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
foreign
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
we got Dr Rachel midicoffer with us
that's right
my favorite political strategist the
best in the nation as far as I'm
concerned uh we have a little scheduling
conflict flick with Senator Doug Jones
he's going to join us at the bottom of
the hour so don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere Dr Rachel Bennett Coffer how
are you
is your mic on like we can't hear you we
can't hear you
get that microphone going show us your
excitement for what happened yesterday
in Wisconsin
oh no ow you'll figure that uh well I
got a tweet that can lead us into this
that is okay yeah you're showing it's
from Ali Alexander as well
oh man well I'm gonna take anything he
says
um right but here's the thing he
is he sees what's going on
he says we just lost the Wisconsin
Supreme Court I do not see a path to 270
in 2024. let's go and talk and come back
in
put someone popular on the ballot it
mobilizes so many voters they won't be
able to fake it for the guy streaming
from his basement absent of that the GOP
has less than 10 percent chance
I mean I guess he's telling the truth
here I mean he he sees the writing on
the wall also I still love the fact that
they're like the guy the for the guy
streaming from the basement the guy that
they say is Sleepy Joe the one who has
somehow been this
guy pulling the puppet strings in the
background you know at the same time
that he's in a basement
it's okay now I can see
perfect perfect we have you now Doc your
sound is up
watch me squinting at the screen
it happens
I needed something to wipe this [__]
eating grin off of my face because I
can't my face is like in pain after like
70 I've been on a 70 hour justices
coming vendor and then Wisconsin all
right so I
so let's start here because I want to
get to the politics of of the
arraignment yesterday
um I actually think that it's you know
we knew kind of what it was going to be
it's exactly what we thought it was it
is it is serious charges this idea that
it's weak and not serious charges is
ridiculous when you're talking about
Donald Trump's intent especially if you
know who he is but let's start let's
let's rewind a bit and go back to the
Wisconsin Supreme Court race tell us why
number one why was this race
so important
yeah I'm gonna let me tell you though
for the indictment stuff it's not what
we expected it's worse for him than what
we expected because the underlying crime
looks pretty solid and we thought maybe
there was going to be a legal argument a
novel legal argument but given what they
laid out
um I'm feeling really good and I know
Joyce Allen who I really trust is a
legal analyst also thought this is a
very steady and um you know normal legal
effort so I think Trump is screwed and
then in terms of Wisconsin guys
Trump gets indicted and within
Republican circles you're like oh this
is going to help us we're going to win
Wisconsin this is going to inflame the
Maga majority right and there is no mega
majority and also we whoop their ass
right 11 points in a Statewide off-year
special election I know people are
caught up that that's similar to our
performance in 2020 but that's a
presidential election cycle and one of
the main drivers of the midterm effect
and our shitty like off presidential
cycle performance over the last decade
we've been fixing it
um is is drop off if participation from
our Coalition which isn't just Democrats
as Independents who will vote for
Democrats right and you know it just
really Ben Wick I'm so proud of Ben
wickler and the Wisconsin Dems they went
all in on negative partisanship and
driving
um you know you know this this new
electoral electioneering strategy all
the way and it and uh trusted it you
know and it's just amazing to see what
they've done there especially under
Ben's leadership so
11 points is big and let me tell you
when it gets Moga tears from Ali
Alexander like this you know you know
that it's huge and you know they're
shaking in their boots let me play
um let me play the uh Gabe do you have
the the the take from the opponent who
lost yeah is Jake last night I think I
have that clip somewhere
um
and the audience will see it here is the
reason why he didn't get elected like
it's the same reason why Carrie Lake
didn't win in Arizona her response is
the exact reason why like this crazy
lunacy that somehow the the people in a
in in a state can't decide for
themselves in an election who they want
to represent them and then you go out
and disparage not just the candidate but
their decision is it's hilarious that
they think this is a winning strategy
got your ass handed to you by 11 [__]
points Tony I mean this is the age of
polarization so when you see data that's
60 support you know um indicting Trump
right like that's those are big [__]
numbers if we were in the 1980s that
[__] would be in the 80s right because
artisanship dictates so much of our
public opinion data now right and so
yeah hell yeah let's show the clip okay
so here here is uh Dan Kelly I believe
his name is well used to be he's not you
know anybody anymore poor guy
um he's pretty I mean he gets pretty
triggered I mean I don't know about the
fact that he lost or the fact that he
lost to a woman that triggers him more
either way it's no you want you want you
want to know what I think it is you know
what I think it is and and and and we'll
uh analyze this after this I actually
think he's really pissed off that women
got out and voted against him and and
because these people these people think
that everyone thinks the way they want
that's why that's why they're pushing
their ideals on us and taking away our
Liberty to live our lives the way that
we want to live them that's why they
want to take choices of the echo chamber
they made right so they made this Echo
chamber reality so they think like the
[__] that they want to do is popular
broadly popular right I mean there's
some fascists like Nick Fuentes who
understands at least now that it's not
pop
it's like 30 [__] percent popular
right but a lot of the party I mean even
even last night we heard a North
Carolina Democrat switch to the
Republican party and I'm like oh lady
you didn't you watch the sequel
on its [__] heels right right hey go
join them have fun that's what I say
here here is uh Dan Kelly with his
response to his loss 11 Point loss last
night
and it brings me no joy to say this
I wish that in a circumstance like this
I would be able to concede to a worthy
opponent
but I do not have a worthy opponent to
which I can conceive what a [__] ass
I'm sorry this guy this guy can try more
[__] okay the fact he's like I didn't
have a worthy of pony Shut the [__] up
man you lost and take it like a man be
[__] own that Alpha status be a
badass be a tough guy and accept the
loss but all of them I mean
the opponent whipped his ass Gabe yeah
right now [__] brain dead do you have
to be to go out on a stage you'd be like
okay by losing by double digits in the
special speed Supreme Court election and
then think your opponent's unworthy dude
yeah it's like getting knocked out in
the first round and then being like ah
[__] it that guy wasn't a worthy
opponent
but the reason why they're losing Rachel
like this in States and and Supreme
Court elections is because of the the
measures of fascism that they're taking
uh last week in Missouri the the fascist
Republicans here in the legislator of
Missouri stripped every single nickel
every dime of like Public Library
funding away because Librarians were
challenging them in court
I mean weaponizing the government and
their budget yes putting putting rural
communities out of touch with with the
rest of the World by cutting off their
libraries which that's some of the only
internet those of those people in those
communities have access to you have in
Tennessee and Tennessee protesters Mass
protesters peaceful protests at the
Capitol demanding demanding after the
Nashville shooting at Covenant School
where three children three teachers were
slaughtered by weapons of war to do
something anything red flag background
anything don't do the law that you're
wanting to do which puts the gun in more
people's hands right that could do this
and and you see three
three Democratic representatives of that
legislator today that are going to be
voted to expel because they were using
their freedom of speech this is supposed
to be the party of freedom and speech
and they they want freedom of speech but
they don't but this is but there is
always Whiplash with these folks we saw
this in Kansas and really that was the
sign for me Rachel that when when Kansas
the Kansas referendum when women went
and said no you're not going to touch
our right to our bodily autonomy but
they still voted for Republicans that
was designed to mean that people are
starting to come around to this idea of
democracy to come around to this idea of
Liberty they really haven't computed of
which party's which yet because we still
have a lot of affiliation vote it is a
challenge that we have in this country
that people vote for affiliation and
nothing more they don't care what the
candidate's name is or what they
represent or the issues my daddy wrote a
republican my daddy's daddy wrote a
Rebecca kind of stuff but but we're
starting to see movement and I know in
Tennessee it's it is it is a it is a
shiv in democracy what is going to
happen there today to try to expel these
members but I will tell you what we
should do with it is to take it all
around the country and tell people this
is what they're trying to do it's not
just Tennessee it's Florida it's Texas
it's Alabama it's Kansas it's Wisconsin
every single state where these people
have power they are trying to use it to
take away your Liberty and your
democracy and it's clear in Tennessee
that's what they're trying to do
Anna I just want to mention uh there's
actually something something that
developed in the last hour is that uh
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer has
signed a bill repealing the state's
nearly Century old abortion ban uh that
revoked a 1931 law that criminalized
abortion so you know this is what she
ran on that's right exactly it's it's
showing you that you know one it you
know it is the will of the people there
is a majority of people who actually
support this but also the fact that the
Democratic party are the only ones who
are actually committing to real agenda
items right not just I'm gonna own the
libs by uh holding up the the deficit or
I'm gonna I'm gonna own the libs by
putting more guns in schools and causing
more debts right they don't actually
care about anyone other than themselves
and the only party that does care are
the Democrats and they're the actual
ones that are pushing through in two
years in two years we will see so much
progress to counteract so many
regressive destruct active damaging acts
that were done in the previous four
years
so and that's why I advocate really
right I mean you run
you run straight at partisanship
Tony um in that Kansas Special there
weren't other elections but if there had
been like State office elections and
that what you would have seen is exactly
what you described we would have seen
these huge margins rejecting their
abortion radicalism but we would have
seen crossover split tickets right where
you know 15 of those a pro abortion
ballots end up voting for republicans
and you've identified exactly what the
problem is they don't realize it right
they don't really connect party on the
right they do because for 10 years 15 20
years their messaging has been about
associating our brand or branding us as
a threat and the more that we do that
and that's exactly what the wiggler team
did in Wisconsin I wasn't working with
Wisconsin but um what they did was they
leaned into partisanship and they gave
the electorate a this or that contrast I
think there's so much power right now
and that this or that contrast you know
um and uh it's just amazing to see it
you know know yielding fruit
it in really tough odds I mean what
should happen in a special for like the
last you know I mean before this last
few years they would they had killed us
in these specials because we we did not
go out and like guns firing make it
about Stakes Framing and emotion and you
know branding right like we would run on
the candidates biography and you know
their platform and we would run some
negative ads but that's a negative
partisanship strategy is you could be
run a positive ad under negative
partisanship strategy two different
things and when you do when you tie them
to their unpopular radical [__]
freaky extremist agenda most Americans
are going to be turned off and that's
how we can hope to start to slice away
at their brand loyalty which is exactly
what they did to us first with the white
working class and now with working class
voters of color
there's a good nugget in there that you
talked about which is like
these special elections right what
happened uh just just yesterday right
this is something where typically people
would not know most people right just
know of the general election then if you
expand out then right then some people
might know about the general
presidential elections
right right exactly right so you've got
the general presidential election and
that's the one that everyone knows about
because that gets the most media
attention then you've got the midterms
where you may or may not know if
something's happening in your own state
or someone's running or you might be
like well it's not their cycle or what
have you and then beyond that now you're
getting into an even more Niche kind of
group which is now you're saying these
special elections that run off randomly
different points or whatever it might be
you're now saying that or now you're
you're showing
that what typically might have been uh
you know a kind of apathetic group of
people that were shown or not showing up
right uh you have people that are
actually showing up you see the margin
in Wisconsin you're seeing people active
being activated to be like holy [__]
there's a lot at stake and I didn't
realize that at first and I really need
to play a part in actually voicing my
concern right by casting a bell with my
vote and so it's it's amazing to see
something that is because it's not just
like one election that matters but it's
all of these elections and people are
beginning to realize that they all have
a domino effect on how one translates
into another I mean Ali Alexander in
that tweet is admitting the fact that
because they didn't win Wisconsin it
hurts their chances for the general
presidential election right because they
want to use the Supreme Court in
Wisconsin overturn elections and
speaking of that speaking of overturning
elections and people who get delusional
about overturning elections yesterday we
saw a historic moment a step forward in
our country where we feet can absolutely
prosecute someone no matter who they are
who they've been and they can be held
accountable under the law and and
everyone is held accountable under the
law yesterday we watched the former
president uh be arraigned on 34 felony
counts and Maga is trying to spend this
is oh this is great for Trump I mean
maybe in the maybe in the primary like
I'm like okay so he wins the primary
then what then what Rachel tell us what
the tell us what the politics are
because I I know that's that's where you
want to go with this tell us what the
politics are and what you see to come
um from Donald Trump and not maybe not
just these 34 felony counts but maybe
other state charges and federal charges
that are to come and courtroom
appearances that he's going to have
yeah he's an albatross right and
Republicans are really [__] because
like you're right
solidify some about his primary support
at least now guys we're in this part of
the primary called The Invisible primary
and really what we're in is the
invisible period of the invisible
primary and that refers to you know the
primary is one's Iowa Starbucks right
that's when you're voting and you're
actively can't you know having election
results but the invisible primary which
used to only be a couple months before
that has now stretched to the day after
the midterm election before it and um I
would expect Trump will hang in there
through the summer maybe but by the fall
and my expectation is we are going to
see more indictments I mean this guy is
a he's not some kind of Master criminal
folks like hilarious and he wasn't
indicted before for his many [__]
Plain Sight crimes is it because of this
made-up presidential immunity Factor
right it's not like we don't know about
his crimes people always want to compare
him to a mom boss I'm like don't [__]
insult Al Capone like that
he's the world's worst mob
um foreign
tax evasion because they are good at
crime and Donald Trump is not good at
crime so you know here's what I think
and I and I kind of got some pushback
from Republican analyst in this meeting
I did with Republicans on Spaces a
couple days ago when I was like look you
guys Trump is a has been dude it's going
to be Ron DeSantis right and I am I am
relatively sure that this is going to be
the case because people are going to
start to sober up come September and
October of 2023 leading into the real
like the meat of the invisible primary
and they're going to be looking at their
multiple I mean Trump's going to have
more more indictments counts and under
indictment than he got Electoral College
votes in 2020 right and you know they're
gonna there's gonna be some buyers fear
now that doesn't mean that Trump's not
gonna get a good healthy margin
especially in this early contests but I
will be surprised if the Republican
party doesn't try very hard to avoid
nominating him my job is to win in 2024
one of many people working on that
problem and so when I look at Donald
Trump I don't I don't have like the PTSD
[__] about what look what happened in 16
we thought he was going to be a terrible
nominee I knew Donald Trump was a threat
the moment he came down that golden
escalator and started talking about
rapist Mexicans right because I know the
American electorate especially on the
right and I knew it was going to be
palatable and um you know unfortunately
it was it was even worse than I could
have imagined right but that's not going
to be that we're not going to see 2016.
the media attention he's getting now bad
okay because it's about getting indicted
and trying to uh you know invoke Civil
War and it's not it's not the same as
showing every speech um while he's in
the field of 20 Republicans I should
know I wrote a book about media
domination in 2016. so I should know and
uh you know as a person who's charged
with saving democracy in 24 uh with
other people you know honestly Trump
would make such a nice nominee here's a
guy who couldn't win the popular vote
both times became president over a freak
accident in the Electoral College and
now is twice impeached and 400
indictments right right like I would
much rather face that I mean there's no
no don't get me wrong I wish he would
just go the [__] away I wish the whole
Republican party would just sober up
they did that tomorrow that would be my
ideal point but that's not going to
happen and I do but I do think that Ron
DeSantis is going to be a formidable
opponent it is not going to have the
baggage unfortunately for him though I
hope he learns this lesson from
Wisconsin he's not going to get away
with that [__] right we we now have
electoral strategies running in this
party that are based on the premise that
you've got to make the electorate look
okay he didn't just magically know the
Republican party is batshit [__] nuts
we have to tell them in our advertising
and we are seeing the fruits of that in
Arizona and Michigan Wisconsin and all
these other places so um yeah bad day
for the GOP
well I couldn't agree with you anymore
on Donald Trump being the worst nominee
that they could pick because there's
there's almost 81 million votes against
Donald Trump and we know exactly where
they are I think that's the most
important thing that people need to
remember the margin of almost 8 million
Democrats know exactly where that margin
lies and yes it probably has grown since
then and it will continue to grow
against Donald Trump and we know where
that margin is in the general election
uh Rachel thanks for joining us again
I'm gonna have to go because I've got
I've got Senator Doug Jones coming up
he's going to talk about he's going to
talk about the Democratic National
Convention coming back to the South he's
got a specific City in mind I think you
might agree with what he's saying um on
where and when but tell us one more time
please before you go where can you find
all all your content because I know you
got a book coming you got a Twitter
that's so important you're always giving
strategy and and how to message and
inform that narrative for the
pro-democracy Coalition tell us where we
go
yeah go to me on Twitter at Rachel
bittickoffer I'm the only one
and uh my book's coming out I think it's
going to be winter of 2024
um and it's coming out with crown which
is a huge huge deal it's going to be a
big book and it's called hit them where
it hurts how to save democracy by
beating Republicans at their own game
and it really touches on a lot of what I
was talking about today running at
partisanship not from it hitting the
Republicans and defining them as a
extremist cult that's dangerous to the
voter not to other marginalized groups
necessarily not to others right to your
own tribe and that's really where loss
aversion kicks in and we see big big
electoral returns
well go check out Rachel on Twitter at
Rachel bittickoffer and check out our
link tree too check out our link tree
there you go right and we gotta oh yeah
there you go Tony
further than the attack guide is there
is that if you want to understand how to
win the messaging War especially if
you're someone like Doug Jones that goes
on TV a lot
there you go well go check out Rachel on
Twitter and go check out her link tree
the Link's there on our Twitter uh and
you can see some of the some of the
great content that she has over there
for you uh Doc it's always a pleasure
having you thank you very much we'll see
you soon my friend okay everybody we got
another guest I I may have messed up the
time I'm not sure exactly but we have
Tony Tony well it happens it happens
this is a live show though we're
flexible you know I'm I'm doing all the
things here I'm the host you know we
gotta we gotta be flexible here we're
doing it live we're doing it live Gabe
do you know that there there is a former
former Democratic senator of Alabama
he's a former Federal prosecutor and
he's also pushing for the Democratic
National Convention to be in the South
and he wanted to come and I wanted to
invite him to come talk about why it is
so important for this to be in the South
but I also I made a strategic move I'll
have to admit uh to Senator Doug Jones
I'm into strategic here I made sure
since he has such expertise on on
prosecutions and indictments I made sure
to have him today after the Trump
arraignment so I could ask him about
that instead of Monday because I really
wanted to make sure we had what was
going to happen yesterday and now today
so maybe he'll he'll like that strategy
move everybody Welcome former Senator
Doug Jones of Alabama Senator how are
you I'm good guys how are you oh we're
doing we're doing great here we're
feeling good for democracy this morning
um it really it really is a day to
celebrate um when we have so many
Republicans out there very disappointed
about what happened in Wisconsin I know
Rachel was talking about it before
um this is the way of the of the
electorate um I I think so many people
no matter where they fall on the
political Spectrum aren't okay with with
any party taking away their Liberty and
taking away their rights and I think
that that probably now is more important
than anywhere in the South because
Republicans have such a strong
stronghold and I know you wanted to talk
about where the Democratic National
Convention could be in the South so so I
wanted to invite you on to talk about
that where do what city I haven't given
it away yet what city do you want the
Democratic National Convention and tell
us why well first of all we're trying to
get it in Atlanta hadn't been in Atlanta
since 1988. but let me let me go back to
something yeah about the Wisconsin uh
and what's going on around you know for
30 or 40 years Republicans have have
been saying we've got to have states
rights we've got to start pushing things
down to the States the Supreme Court in
the Roe versus Wade overturning
decisions said let's push all this down
to the States well you know instead of
totally fighting all of that Democrats
are saying all right my God we're going
to embrace that and we will go
toe-to-toe with you in every state on
issues like women's Reproductive Rights
like on sensible regulations of firearms
like all of the things that kitchen
table issues that I ran on in 2017 and
guess what we're winning those races we
are we are getting because people now
are seeing that where you make a
difference in this country is at the
local level and the state level it is
not necessarily you're a senator or your
president it is where the rubber meets
the road on a local level Tony so
um I'm really excited to be working with
a group of folks to try to get
the DNC convention uh back in Atlanta
after you know close to 40-year uh
absence uh in the Deep South it was we
were in Charlotte a few years back
um but Georgia represents something more
I think important for the party and I
think for America because it is where
the Democratic party can grow in the
South we've grown in Georgia we have now
Joe Biden won the state of Georgia the
first time in a long time that a
Democratic presidential candidate
carried that state we've got now two
Democratic United States senators no one
should think that that Georgia is blue
because of that because you've still got
Brian Kemp and all the Statewide
electives but clearly there are things
in Georgia that they have been doing for
a long time and doing exactly what I've
been trying to tell folks and uh in in
Alabama and South Carolina and elsewhere
and that's played long ball things are
changing in the South and the Democrats
have an opportunity to grow in the South
where you're kind of locked in in so
many other states so that's number one
number two is that the heart of the
democratic party is the African-American
vote and it has been for decades now and
we are recognizing that we're rewarding
that in Atlanta is the heart of that
movement Dr King preached there John
Lewis lived there it is we're the heart
of the civil rights movement has been
and emanated from throughout the to the
rest of of the South so you're going to
celebrate that as well and I think
between all of that it just makes sense
for this convention to go to Atlanta for
Joe Biden to have that convention in a
city that he carried in a state that he
carried in fact this convention if it if
if Atlanta is lucky enough
will be held at a site where Joe Biden
carried the electorate by 40 000 votes
and he only won the state by about 11 or
12 000 votes so it's a big it's it's an
important thing for I think this
president to claim that mantle uh and be
able to do the things he's done uh for
the folks in the South and for the party
to say we're coming after you we're
gonna we're not giving ground to any
vote anymore uh we're gonna we're gonna
fight and compete all over and
especially in the South so that's my
elevators [__] buddy well I think I
think I think it's great because
um I I grew up in Central Missouri which
um isn't exactly the South but sometimes
it's we're kind of the red-headed
stepchild of the South if I can say that
but I I will I will say that a lot of
people don't know because I always fight
for the word liberal I really do I think
liberalism is the strength of our
country it's it's our it's our founding
principles as liberalism
um and and I think that's the position
that we come from and I think so many
people in this country that we write off
that that may not know their liberals
you know they want they don't want to go
broke because of a medical bill they
don't they don't want they don't want to
have a big huge bill because of college
they want to make sure their kids start
school at three instead of five and not
have to pay those big huge High Day Care
bills for that extra two years I mean
they want all these things everyone
wants decent wages they don't want their
social security and their Medicare and
their and their Medicaid safety net to
go away and all that is the strength of
liberalism and I think the South just
hasn't hurt us loud enough yet they
haven't heard us loud enough you're
absolutely correct and let's let's be
very candid about this okay if you go
back uh 50 years to the height of the
Civil Rights Movement liberal literally
meant only that you were for civil
rights and integration
and if you were conservative you wanted
the status quo and you were okay with
Jim Crow that's where all of this really
started and that's where we we I think a
lot of the Democrats and progressives
have let others Define Us in ways that
are just not true
um and you're absolutely right
um about what people care in the south
care about uh it's just that they've
been sidetracked on these culture wars
and we've got to pull people back I
think I I'll be honest with you I don't
really care what label it is I used to
tell people when they asked me when I
was in the Senate where you are are you
a liberal Democrat are you a national
Democrat are you a southern Democrat are
you a moderate I said hell I'm a dog
Democrat I am what you get okay and I
think if people see all of the the
issues that we've got uh in the South
that people are struggling every day and
you rattled off every one of them people
in this house still
care about those issues they care about
their communities they care about their
families and they let people exploit
them sometimes and they shouldn't and
Democrats have not always talked to them
they've not listened to them they've not
talked to them they've tried to kind of
explain how we know better for you well
that's just not the way you talk to
folks uh down here so I we've got this
opportunity I really believe and we have
been we've been getting such incredible
feedback across the country about what
we're trying to do for Atlanta and in
the South our social media has blown up
with a hashtag good trouble 2024.
um and go for it look at it on Twitter
you'll see what I'm talking about so I
think there's some really interesting
opportunities here but the main thing
and I'm just and I'm not going to say
anything I haven't said in a publicly
for a long time now the Democrats just
abandoned the South about 30 40 years
ago they just basically said we're going
to give up on you guys
um you're just way way way off the
charts we're just going to give up that
was a huge mistake but now people are
seeing the Investments that can be made
in a state like Georgia and in other
places it's a long-term strategy but
we've got to make sure we make these
Investments and and I think the party
can demonstrate an incredible message by
going to the heart of the Civil Rights
Movement the heart of the South uh and
saying we're here to play
well I love the hashtag good trouble
um because it is the words of um the
late great John Lewis and and Atlanta is
the heart of the South and the civil
rights movement and I think it's very
fitting uh for Democrats to go there and
and like you said fight for the South
because it's not it's not about fighting
for for votes and and you know I we
politicize stuff on the show and we make
this all political but really it's about
fighting for those people to be part of
the liberal democracy that we all want
that we all cherish that we all want to
be a part of and and why it's so
important because Wisconsin was a big
victory in the north but we can have big
victories in the South we really can now
I would be derelict in my duty if I had
a former Federal prosecutor on
um who has had long battles where you
held people accountable that weren't
accountable for 40 years I was reviewing
some things some cases that you've had
before in your past as a prosecutor but
yesterday we we crossed to Rubicon in
this country and I actually don't think
it's a bad Rubicon for politicians
especially High politicians who have
carried a lot of power to be held
accountable for their crimes I believe
um in Law and Order I think everyone is
held accountable under why I think
yesterday we proved that as a country
that we can move move forward in doing
that but what's your take on what
happened yesterday maybe the imagery but
even maybe the indictment have you had a
chance to review these charges yeah you
know I've looked at this a little bit
and let me say Tony you know I don't
disagree with you at all that it was a
bad Rubicon to cross the whole people
accountable we've we've done that across
the board with Senators members of
congress with Governors with Mayors
um but this is the first time we've
crossed it with a uh a former president
United States having said that though
you still have to admit that it's not a
good day for America when when when
something like this happens but it
wasn't a good day for America when we
elected him in the first place I mean as
he came down those golden uh that golden
escalator we should have been right then
seen what was to to the chaos that was
to become and and he he said then uh
during that campaign that he could shoot
somebody on Fifth Avenue and not lose
any votes he didn't say though that he
would not be held accountable by law
enforcement and I think over the last
few years he has demonstrated that he
believes he is unaccountable to law
enforcement so yes there is it is a it's
a mixed bag with what we saw yesterday
um but the fact of the matter is
it's not a political this is not a
political uh persecution it has not been
a Witch Hunt the only person that has
put Donald Trump in the position he is
in is Donald Trump
um and it's a myriad of Investigations
that are going on right now uh I think
that the charges are serious charges
um you know one thing that at first
blush the average person will say this
is just falsifying business records but
that DA's office does have a history of
Prosecuting falsification of business
records
um a long history of doing that now I
will say that there are some legal
issues that I think are going to be
really interesting to watch because
you've got a state court state law
prosecutor and a federal candidate for
president and there is some blending
that he is doing with regard to the
cover-up it's it's not illegal to pay
hush money to a point store is sorted as
that might be right
um which goes back to this whole
election issue
um
it that in and of itself is not illegal
they're trying to tie this to an
illegality of an of a state election law
which I think poses a significant legal
issue then I'm sure that they have
researched they're trying to tie it to a
potential federal election violation on
a uh busting the caps on contributions
of which I'm well aware
um so that's going to be an interesting
legal issue and then there's a potential
tax consequence uh to some of this
because you can't write off hush money
you can write off legal fees so there
are a lot of nuances here this is long
uh it's not going to be over anytime
soon he is going to mount a very
vigorous defense and I think that this
judge is going to be faced with some
really interesting legal uh issues that
he has decide to decide before this case
goes to trial but this is just the this
is just the first shoe to drop I think
right now given what's going on in
George Georgia in State Court there
given what the special counsel is
looking at with regard to the election
as well as the Mar-A-Lago documents
um Donald Trump's going to be fighting
legal battles on a myriad of fronts
right now and we don't know where they
will ultimately end up the thing that I
I'm getting a little tired of in all
Candor to my friends in the media
everybody trying to analyze the strength
and weaknesses and we're people are they
don't know they don't know what the
evidence is the grand juries operate in
secret and yeah there's leaks and you
have some ideas but nobody really knows
how all of this is going to turn out but
regardless
we do know this that the facts of all of
these cases uh are not pretty and they
are they are in fact are just downright
ugly and it is a sad State of Affairs
when a president United States embarks
on the activity that is the subject of
these lawsuits regardless of whether it
is Ultimate criminal liability or not
I think um the fact that Alvin Bragg is
holding it close to the chest and by
that I mean what criminal or what crime
he's saying that Trump had the intent to
cover up with these business
transactions I think is very significant
we were talking about it earlier that
um it feels like to me because there was
34 separate charges as opposed to just
one charge because apparently you can do
either with a grand jury as a as a D.A
in the state of New York
um but I think the significant part of
that is that Alvin Bragg is signaling
not just to Donald Trump and his legal
team but to to everyone that hey there
is evidence of intent to cover a crime
with each one of these business
transactions and the jury was willing to
vote for Ev all 34 of those I think
that's significant and I think that's
being missed as this is just a low level
why would you bring this case I think
this is much more serious than evil even
some of the legal analysis like you said
in the media are giving that hey this is
a serious deal it doesn't matter if he's
a former president or a setting Senator
or former Senator or Governor 34
criminal felony counts in the state of
New York on business charges where
there's an underlying conspiracy to
cover up a crime I think it's pretty
pretty serious sure absolutely and and
again and I think this is getting lost
as well is that this office has a
history of bringing these crimes it's
not like this is something new that they
never pursue that they have a policy
we're just going to let that slide and
do it in a civil court and try to recoup
the money or whatever it might be they
bring these charges and people have been
convicted of them so if we got a long
way to go I think in all of these and
there's going to be some really
interesting legal things that come out
of this
um but again you've got Georgia you've
got two different investigations that
the special counsel is looking at all of
which are going to continue to occupy
um Donald Trump's days in in weeks and
months for the next foreseeable future
yeah I would definitely I want to add to
that you know the thing that you hear on
online right now especially on Twitter
you have a bunch of armchair lawyers who
want to give their legal take on say
well it's not that big of a deal or it's
not that bad you know despite the fact
that you know former Federal prosecutors
or current like yourself you know are
are saying uh actually there's more to
it than you think there is right there's
there's a reason why they brought this
there's a reason why they separated
there's a reason why they've played this
so close to the chest and not allowed
this stuff to come out I mean like we
don't know how long the grand jury's
been you know uh together for the last
few months or whatever but this is a
serious case and so are the other ones
and it's just interesting to see people
be like oh well this is gonna you know
this is gonna make Trump a martyr and
you just guarantee 2024 and it's like
did the guy we've gone until right now
this guy I think December 4th or
December 5th is when the actual next
appearance in court is whether or not
that gets pushed for going back and
forth oh I'm sure it certainly will yeah
yeah but I mean like it's something
that's like well you're great you know
what you did you just put Democrats in a
better position because you're literally
writing the tv ads for the Democratic
party to prove why this guy is not the
person that one you think he is or two
he's exactly who you think he is and he
shouldn't be in office right and I and I
think that a lot of the to bring it back
I think a lot of these people are like
oh well you know I'm reading these my
God that's not a big deal it's like well
when you look at the whole merits of the
case and this is only what we know right
now you know I'm sure more will be
revealed as the actual trial opens up
about these things and look
you know I got to be honest with you I
was traveling all day yesterday so I
just kept trying to listen on the radio
uh about some of this and and didn't
really get a chance to look at it until
later last night and again uh this
morning and you know you've got an
indictment that charges but then you've
got this statement of facts that kind of
lays all this out in a little bit more
detail and well significantly more
detail and I think it's easy it was and
and I had the same initial reaction that
this is this just seems to be a little
bit of overreach
but I'm gonna give Alvin Bragg the
benefit of the doubt here because he is
a really smart lawyer he was hired as an
assistant U.S attorney by my friend my
friend uh preet Bara who I think is one
of the great uh public servants and
prosecutors that we've had in the
Department of Justice
um he's worked as an assistant D.A you
know that all of these legal issues have
been vetted by his very well-trained
staff
and when people say these are really not
serious charges the issue is well does
it what's fascinating about that is the
Republicans say oh these are not serious
they should just they should just ignore
this well it's a it's a statute on the
books and there are similar statues in
other states around the country and the
same Republicans are saying oh this is
not that Syria should ignore it will
criticize district attorneys for not
Prosecuting certain things that they
think should be prosecuted I mean it the
hypocrisy here is pretty stunning and
there's no greater hypocrisy than
someone like Donald Trump screaming
about a political Witch Hunt when the
primary chant at his rallies is was not
we're for you Donald it was lock her up
and he has promoted investigations about
political enemies from day one and so I
think people need to just kind of let
this play out we have a system of
Criminal Justice that involves an
elected prosecutor
who has sworn to do a job to uphold the
books the statutes and the criminal
statutes that are on the books in the
state of New York and ultimately us we
have a judge who is going to rule on
whether or not this case should go to
trial or be dismissed if it goes to
trial then you will have 12 men and
women who will judge the facts in the
law and that's what this system is all
about they don't always get it right but
by and large the system works and we
need to really sit back and let this
system work because we don't know
everything that Alvin Bragg has we don't
know everything that the defense has in
this and Donald Trump with all that we
can say and do and all that we know
about him under the law and rightly so
he is presumed to be innocent of these
charges and that presumption of
innocence is a strong presumption that
carries weight and a jury has to find
not that they just probably did this but
they that he that they believe he did it
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt a doubt based
on reason one that would cause you to
hesitate in the most important of your
own Affairs so we have a long way to go
we need to let this play out we need to
not try to do too much analysis of it
but uh I do have at least some
confidence of two things number one that
this DA's office has looked at this from
every way but Sunday
um to to make sure they have their eyes
dotted and the t's crossed uh and second
of all that this is not a political
issue but one of the conduct of the
former president of the United States
well Senator Doug Jones I appreciate you
coming and joining us give us one last
cell for why the Democratic National
Convention should go to Atlanta for good
trouble in 2024. because it just makes
sense if you look at where the
Democratic party needs to continue their
growth and the message they need to send
it is right here in the South we can
make a difference in this country if
Democrats can make a difference in the
south well thank you very much Senator
Doug Jones everyone thanks for joining
us sorry about the time mix up well
here's what I'll say here's what I say
when we get it I can't oh well it
happened
here here's what I'll tell you when we
when you get in Atlanta when we land
this deal in Atlanta we'll have you back
and we'll celebrate okay sounds good
thank you very much sir we appreciate it
we appreciate having you here thank you
Senator Doug Jones holy moly we just
have a great lineup today you know what
I'm saying Dr Rachel been a coffer
former Senator Doug Jones given us the
lowdown on why why the Democrats should
have the convention in Atlanta for for
for pro-democracy reasons and showing
this out that hey if you're for
democracy we might be your we might be
the party that you're interested in and
also giving us the lowdown on some of
these uh charges that came from the
Manhattan d8 yesterday Alvin Bragg he
brings up a good point about Alvin Bragg
like this like
when you go to these Twitter spaces they
act like Alvin Brown like just left law
school yesterday like well yeah not only
that somehow just a Ding-A-Ling or
something now look at that look at this
nobody doing this it's funny because
they they're like oh Alvin Bragg over a
stepped he shouldn't have done this oh
man he's overplaying his hands look we
need to quickly just take a step back if
you were to look at the background of
Alvin Bragg and understand you know his
actual legal training but not only that
but the fact that they're like oh he's
St he's you know all these people in
these Twitter spaces want to be like oh
there's rumors and Rumblings inside the
office that Alvin Bragg went rogue and
he's doing his own thing and people
aren't agreeing with them and this and
that and and then on top of that they're
like oh also he's been in his hole his
whole career on this to take down uh
Donald Trump because that's what he he
campaigned on and it's like he did not
campaign on that and he is not doing
this because you can only imagine what
somebody would do and here's the thing
the reason alphabra I mean we again we
don't know the evidence that Alvin Bragg
has we just know these counts that have
been listed so we don't know what
evidence they're going to throw to be
like look here's this for is this hint
because you're intense and here and the
intent because what's going to happen is
or what you're seeing is Republicans are
freaking out right they see the end is
near but they don't want to accept it
and so they're doing everything they can
to be like this judge this judge should
should recuse himself they shouldn't try
this case this and that it's like why
are you guys freaking out if you really
believed in Law and Order and you really
believe that he's innocent and you
really believe that he has the the legal
team to defend him
then there should be nothing to worry
about right then don't worry about it
however the reason they're freaking out
and the reason they're up in arms and
having a tantrum and whining and saying
oh man odd this and that and Donald
Trump just secured the presidency [__]
it whatever
you wouldn't be freaking out if you
actually believed in the things that you
projected before that right if you
really believed in just comply don't
resist Law and Order you know we gotta
we gotta trust the legal system but now
you're saying oh there's a two-tier
justicism justicism and and this isn't
fair and he's a presidential candidate
it's like well but here's the thing is
that it the whole strategy of of their
messaging
it's not working yeah and let me let me
show you an example their message their
messaging is own the libs right like
that full stop that's the only thing
that's the only policy they really have
anymore is own the lips let me show you
in Wisconsin yesterday how how it went
for them owning the libs if you watch
this is a voting station at one of the
colleges there this is Gen Z showing the
Republicans how they're owning the libs
like look I get it that you want to try
to make people upset right and and
you're and you're doing it by trying to
take away people's Liberty you're doing
it by trying to Gaslight us and to think
that the law can't uh hold everyone
accountable no matter who you are or
what office you've held and somehow the
country is going to go into shambles
because the former president United
States you committed crime before he was
the president while he was president and
after he was president that we can't
hold this guy accountable in this
country where we don't want to order
exists you know what this is what's that
this is what happens when you kick the
[__] Hornet's Nest right and and and
and think oh it's going to be totally
fine right they're going to come out and
they're gonna see you as the the the
threat and they're going to neutralize
you right and and this is one of those
moments where you've got gen Z you know
thank God for Gen Z looking at this and
saying nah we're not gonna take this
[__] anymore okay I'm not gonna live the
rest of my adult and you know further on
type of life where I have to not have uh
uh control over my body I don't have the
say I want in terms of where or what I
can do in public right these are all
things that gen Z
is experiencing firsthand right
uh and and not willing to accept the the
outcome of what happens if they don't do
anything right you're see you you we saw
it you know uh we saw it on
uh
on in New York right in front of the in
front of the Manhattan Courthouse we saw
people that were just schooling Harry
was down there who's a gen zero was
[__] schooling right Mega idiots it
was amazing to see you've got people
that are uh in Georgia you've got people
that are in other places that are that
are fighting for their rights Tennessee
Nashville just because three people
three rep state representatives said oh
you know what I believe and I want to
support those students who are saying we
need better gun laws now this fascist
Republican entity within the state
government is saying oh you know what
we're going to take away your access you
can't vote you're not in the Committees
and we're going to expel you completely
like you tell me right now that that's
fair that that is democracy like that's
not that's not fair and gen Z is like
we're [__] not having this man well
you can't do this anymore and and
they're succeeding they won yesterday by
11 points now I I I'll I'll say that I
don't think the entire uh generation of
gen Z is what put which kind of yeah
over over the line but listen folks gen
Z is a big part of the democratic
Coalition and the reason why this
generation is so important is because
their entire lives leading up to them
being the young adults they are now has
been led by people telling them that the
the greatest generations of America is
over and that they've been hiding I
trained to hide underneath their desk
and hiding closets away from Shooters I
mean this this generation gets why we
have to have Liberty and freedom in this
country they understand what it means to
have the right to live they understand
what it means to have the right and
freedom of choice
um unlike the Trump generation or the
Maga in this country here's a great
example of how Maga went yesterday on
the internet and worldwide
um this this video really plays it out
really well you can see a big banner
here it says Trump lies all the time
which I don't see any lions in four
years he was President he sold he told
over thirty thousand lives right he lies
all the time
um and this woman in a manga hat
um is really mad about this Banner but
watch what happens when she tries to own
the libs when she tries to own the libs
this is what happens to manga when they
try to own the lids let me show you
hey
[Applause]
oh oh oh it's like grape stomp lady
right you know oh man it's it is funny
it is it is it is funny to watch uh
people on the right try to own the lives
because what ends up happening is
actually hearing and they're saying this
clip we didn't play this yesterday and I
wanted to but obviously the indictment
was uh yeah well we had three hours and
we still didn't have time to get to all
this I know but this one this is the
video I wanted to play Yesterday of Kid
Rock oh yes this is great I watched this
afterwards because I was like what's
this [__] about but like I I so
apparently apparently it's just that the
thing is is that they're mad because Bud
Light has Dei diversity equity and
inclusion like that's yeah they're upset
that you know on the cans and on the
packaging there's a regular bid God
forbid there's a rainbow and it's got
Pro lgbtq scary rainbows right scary
rainbows I mean I mean did they are
rainbows are terrifying Gabe Sanchez I
tell you what have you ever seen a mass
Rave mowing out there do you see have
you ever seen what rainbows do to
Children's bodies
rainbowing at schools I've never seen a
mass rainbow oh my God I have seen a
double rainbow a double well double
rainbowing I tell you what you talking
you talk about dead bodies everywhere
these these these rainbows let me take
they're manufacturing and designed to
kill to kill conservative human beings
I'm telling you it's the truth Rainbows
are deadly and dangerous my friend and
they're not just deadly Neighbors in the
sky they're deadly dangerous on t-shirts
we watch that in a clip further and
apparently apparently according to get
rock they're very dangerous deadly on
beer cans so much so that he went out
and bought three cases of beer he bought
three cases of beer so he could do this
this is dumb as [__] but let's watch it
Grandpa's feeling a little frisky today
what what okay wait wait a second
Grandpa I'm sorry what was that is he
Grant is he a grandpa is that what he's
saying he's he's well he's 52 right or
something right well I mean he looks old
as [__] man yeah yeah well this is what
happens hatred and racism does it has
been scientifically proven to age your
body that's why it looks so damn young
you know I I'm actually I'm actually 63
but yeah yeah yeah I'm actually 47.
that's what that's what love and
Rainbow's a Didier yeah here's the thing
a lot of people don't know this kid rock
the only reason why this guy's famous is
because he comes from wealth and they
like bought they bought him into being
some music star he's got a couple songs
one song that he wrote that he can
barely sing it I don't know if you've
you know you know what sometime picture
with Cheryl Crow oh yeah his famous
karaoke songs it's a great song actually
I like the lyrics I like the sentiment
he wrote it and it's unbelievable when I
hear it that he actually wrote it but
have you ever heard him sing it live
He's horrible horrible oh yeah yeah he's
not he's not a great so bad like all his
that's why that's why the guitar and the
drums are so much louder
you know like right
I mean he can't right but this is this
is the thing but you're gonna understand
why he doesn't just suck at music here
let me show you he doesn't just suck at
music he sucks at a lot of things but
let me show it
let me uh say something to all you and B
as clear and concise as possible I doubt
it but yeah go ahead
oh you're oh you're gonna you're gonna
get out your little dick energy oh I see
yeah yeah okay wow so wait wait I I I I
misspoke I misspoke he bought four cases
of Bud Light here yeah he bought four
cases which you know I mean you know
what what's it what's a 30 rack like 20
some bucks right I don't know you
probably spent 100 hours yeah probably
with taxes 80 100 bucks something like
that if I had to guess you're saying
these are 30 yeah they're cans these
aren't bottles yeah it's Thirty oh okay
see I thought I thought this was I
thought this was I thought he would be
classy enough Jesus Christ I'm not even
be classy enough to buy bottles no no
because bottles that's he has to then he
has to pick the glass up off the grass
and if he's a grandpa and he can't have
those kids running around the grass you
know because that's super woke oh my God
but the the funny the funny part about
this because like in my tweet I was like
you know tell me you're triggered by the
Bud Lights uh literally triggered
literally you are triggered Yeah by Tran
by Bud lights Trans campaign without
telling me you're being triggered by you
know this campaign and the other thing
too is like the guy is like 50 feet away
60 feet Max and he [__] misses right
with the [__] machine gun right
that's what I'm saying he's horrible at
music and he's an assault rifle or
whatever you want to call it like
whatever thing it's a [__] thing that
shoots multiple a little energy rifle
that he has there
and he [__] misses there's two cases
on the left side and maybe he hits them
most of those bullets if you watch go
into the [__] Pond what's funny is
I'm Betty bought another case of this
[__] to drink oh one oh you sent he
probably got down he was like he
probably sat down on his little chair on
his on his porch pulled out his phone
hit post and then cracked open a bud
line go uh my fans are so stupid you
know what you know what's funny about
this too like Anheuser-Busch would see
this like yeah do this every day man
that's like four cases of beer a day
keep at it really but that's the thing
it's like Nick Adams buying the M M's
and saying yeah
Seb Gorka bought a six-pack maybe that's
why I had bottles in my mind because Seb
gork has got a little more class than
than [__] Kid Rock I guess he bought
bottles instead of cans which I'm not
against cans people you know sometimes
if you're gonna shoot something I would
want to shoot a bottle of glass well
that's yeah yeah I get that yeah I mean
can is good for target practice but if
you're gonna make a spectacle or
something you want to make [__]
shatter you know what I mean oh yeah
yeah yeah or at least or at least stack
them up and show me give me a pyramid
and break it up that would have been
great I think this guy could do a
pyramid though you think he's smart
enough to get it no I think I think is
there anything after he shoots this does
he say anything
oh he's cool [__] Bud Light yep there we
go [__] high as a bush have a
terrific day and you know and you know
what you know what Anheuser-Busch says
they were like uh dude why'd you miss so
many cans man right right like that's it
we're more insulted by the fact that you
missed cans than you actually shooting
the cans but again feel free buy more of
our products just attract [__]
it's just like also the fact that it's
you know I know that people want to say
like oh bad press is good press right
and or
all that [__] where especially if people
want to compare it with Donald Trump
they're like oh all this negative press
right now is super good pres for down
it's like no no no no that's no that's
not good for him
but in this moment right here he is now
basically showing improving
that there are transphobic people that
exist in our country who do not see
anyone from the lgbtq community or
homophobic transphobic all of this stuff
who do not see them as real people
and it only makes them look like the
villain because they got so mad and so
triggered that they had to buy beer and
shoot it because God forbid a trans
activist had their face on the cam gape
are you saying they think they aren't
the villain they don't think they're the
best no no no they don't they don't
think they're the baddies oh yeah I
thought I thought they thought they was
no no no there they don't think they're
the baddest they don't think they're the
heroes
they think they're the heroes in this
movie called life and whenever they do
these things they go I'm just liberating
us from the tyranny of these woke ass
companies and Country
I think it's hilarious they're war on
wokeism because it's working out
perfectly for them like it did yesterday
in Wisconsin like like it is working in
Tennessee because it's actually working
again some people are paying attention
to what you're doing we're we're we see
you fascist we see you and we see your
dumb stupid culture wars that make no
sense when you're trying to legislate or
get rid of rainbows on beer cans you
[__] snowflake [__] ass [__]
that's all you are whining it crying
about rainbows on t-shirts and beer cans
are you kidding me what do you want a
[__] participation trophy you [__]
Maga Republicans is that where you are
is are you the generation of
participation trophies you snowflakes
I don't know I hope they keep trying to
own the libs yeah and we'll keep track
of them here on the Tony Michaels
podcast as always
every single weekday Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours
what a great show Dr Rachel witticoffer
and Senator Doug Jones
that's that I think that's like a
milestone that's too high we might we
also I have to double check but we might
have a guest for tomorrow oh really yeah
oh I I didn't I wasn't I I did not know
this but I'm excited to hear in the
background who this yes might be it's
about it's uh if she's still available I
have to double check but it sounds like
she wants to talk about what's going on
in uh in Idaho which is around the
abortion trafficking oh okay well I'm
very interested in having a guest on to
talk about anywhere fascism is trying to
take over our country whether it's Idaho
Missouri Wisconsin Georgia Alabama
Tennessee Texas Florida wherever it lies
we will be there we will be holding it
accountable right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday so
don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube and download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify Google check
out Gabe's new what was that over at
what was that show.com there's a new
episode out right now there you go go
check it out on patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez while you're on patreon check my
page out to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels we're gonna do some wild [__]
over there I'm telling you you're not
going to want to miss the patreon party
I do want to announce I'm moving it from
Easter weekend this weekend to the next
weekend because it didn't make sense to
have it on Easter weekend that's my
fault I'm not ready wow you didn't want
to rise up on the Thursday
I just know I forgot it was Easter so
we're gonna push it to the next weekend
that way everyone has a chance to watch
Gabe you're invited to come hang out and
have some shots of Jaeger you have to do
Jaeger though that is what you have
everyone follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels and also follow the
upwire.com go subscribe to their YouTube
channel we broadcast live over there
every day if you have an Amazon Prime
account make sure that you're using it
as as best you can here's what you do
you tie your Amazon Prime account to a
Twitch account and you give us that one
free subscription that you get on your
Prime account and we get a couple
dollars of Amazon's money over on Twitch
so don't forget if you have an Amazon
Prime account to tie it to your Twitch
account link them up and then give us
that one free subscription also if
you've given us that subscription
apparently you have to go in every month
and renew it so if you haven't done that
go in and renew that subscription so we
get Jeff bezos's couple bucks for your
free subscription doesn't cost you
anything yeah do anything so I tell you
what you don't want to do you know what
you do not want to miss this show you
don't want to miss it every single
weekday like tomorrow we're going to be
back here same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon